so you know my the the charge to me and
from the organizers of the workshop was
to uh
um
it was to
sort of highlight um the thread that
goes through many of the results in this
in this workshop and um so let me start
with um with um
you know parlor game that many of us
used to play
at least in the early days of
quantum computing which is uh
um
how do we explain the power of oh my god
so
what much happens here
um
maybe
okay
how do we explain the this this um
you know the power of quantum mechanics
and um
you know obviously there are
there are many ways to answer this
question so
you know one of the
um
you know one of the standard ways to
answer it is
well look there are exponentially many
parameters that you need to describe
a quantum state
as opposed to a classical state
well
you know it's it's true that that you
have an exponentially large hilbert
space
but then
if you think of a probabilistic system
then
you know to describe a probability
distribution on n bits you also require
exponential amount of information
so
well then
um
you know another thing you can say is
well it's really entanglement that's
that's really the key to
to
you know the difference between quantum
mechanics and classical
physics and and again uh
um you know if you do the
analogy with with probabilistic systems
then entanglement really corresponds to
correlations
and so it's you know
again you know all these are correct
answers but but it's it's a very
slippery situation and it's not clear
that any of them really
um you know
you know gets gets one's hands on what's
what's really the difference
so you can go a little further and you
can say it's the fact that you can work
in different bases
and again you know as we'll see the you
know this may not
really com you know uh get at the
difference so
and then there's this final um
you know the difference which is
maybe it's because it's l2 versus l1
right so quantum mechanics is linear
except for the fact that there's this
one
uh you know there's this one operation
at the end when you are measuring your
quantum state
which is non-linear
right because because when you measure
the state you see
x with probability alpha x magnitude
squared
and maybe this is where the where the
where the
you know crux of quantumness comes in
so in any case let's um you know what
what i'm what i'm going to do is i'll
i'll start by describing something that
i i hope most of you know which is uh
which is uh these tests for
quantumness which actually started with
with uh
with the epr challenge to
to quantum mechanics
as a thought experiment and then you
know about 30 years later uh john bell
realized that in fact if you if you
looked sufficiently deeply into this
into this paradox you could actually
find
a test for for quantumness
and um
uh so so the the version of this that
i'll describe
is
is the chsh game which is um which is a
simplification just you know most of the
things i'll say today you know apply
more generally but but
but this will be a very nice way to
think about these these uh
these issues um
you know and this is probably the form
that that has been tested uh
experimentally
so
so so what i want to do is um is you
know i want to start by describing the
chsh game and then
then i'd like to
you know which which i hope most of you
have seen but
but i'll go through it anyway and then
i'll i'll start trying to
look at it very naively from the point
of view of where's this test for
quantumness what
where's this difference between quantum
and classical really coming in you know
from from the same viewpoint of the of
that parlor game
okay so so what's the chsh game i'm sure
you've seen it so you know you have two
players who cannot communicate with each
other
and
they're given as input random bits x and
y and they output
bits a a and b
all classical and
the game in the game what they are
trying to do is maximize the probability
that x times y equal to a x or b
now it's
it's actually um
easy to see that that there's no that
classically it's impossible to do better
than three quarters and the argument
sort of goes like this it's a parity
argument it says well they're are really
four cases and and and the alice and bob
cannot win in all four and the reason is
that that if you look at this output a x
or b
and if you sum it up over all four
possibilities the right side is even and
the left side has to be all because x
times y is one on exactly one of the
four inputs and so
so you you've got to fail on one of the
four inputs and so you have a three at
most three quarter chance of success
on the other hand what we know is that
if if if a and b
share entangled qubits
or
or a bell pair then they can achieve a
success probability of cosine squared pi
by 8 or 0.85
and so this
this constitutes a test that there's
something quantum going on
right so if you if you end up getting
this violation of this three-quarters
band then then you have a test for
quantumness
okay so so now let's let's go back and
you know
go back to this this uh this question
about what what's the
where does it really you know where does
this quantumness really come from
so
of course the first thing you can say is
well when you when you take your belt
pair and you measure it
um measure the two qubits you know the
two qubits are far apart you get the
same outcome zero zero on both sides or
one on both sides
but of course
this is not yet quantumness right this
is just shared randomness
you get a random bit and it's completely
correlated but that's that's just
perfectly correlated random bits so so
nothing nothing interesting there yet
okay so
so so now comes the very interesting
part about about
about a bell state which is
that
the bell state is rotationally invariant
which means that
you can you can measure it in any
rotated
you you perp
and now
the fact is that
what we'll get um on each side is a
random outcome
but in fact the random outcome is going
to be perfectly correlated no matter
which basis we measure it in
right and now we could say well
surely this is where the quantumness
comes in the fact that you know you can
change bases
and no matter which bases you're you're
looking in you always see the same the
perfectly correlated result on each side
so surely that's not just shared
randomness that's something quantum
going on
and you know this is this is not
something we should be able to reproduce
classically
okay so
well let's try to reproduce it
classically
so so let's say that we have
we have a coin a classical coin actually
two classical coins
one for alice one for bob you know so
they were they were born together so
they were they were both randomly you
know we picked a random
alignment for for each coin and and we
separate them out over you know as alice
and bob go far apart
and then
um and then corresponding to this random
measurement measurement in a random
basis we alice looks at it from a random
direction
alice picks a random direction to look
at her coin from
and bob picks the same random direction
so these are these aligned bases in
which they are making a measurement
now of course
because the coins are perfectly aligned
and the measurement
directions are perfectly aligned they'll
both see the same side of the coin both
heads of both tails
right and so so we have what we have
reproduced is exactly what we what we
had in the
in the in the classical case which is
which is that the outcome is perfectly
random you know with respect to fixed
basis but then but then if you look with
respect to any basis
first of all that the output is basis
you know it's it's dependent upon which
direction you look from and secondly if
you look at both coins from the same
direction you always see the same
outcome
okay so so again you know this is not
whether where the quantumness comes in
quite yet
so so where does this test for
quantumness really come in well
okay so so now what we do is we
what we're going to do is is measure
uh
you know the left qubit
in
in the uu purp basis
and measure the right one in the vv purp
basis
and let's say that these these two bases
make an angle of theta with each other
so now
what what happens when we when we
measure the two qubits in these these
bases well when we measure the first
cubit we either get you or you perp so
let's say we got you the usda outcome
so so now the
the you know from what we said already
um
in this case the second qubit is
definitely in the state view and now
when we measure this cubit in the v v
perp basis we see b with probability
cosine square theta
and so so the char probability of
getting matching outcomes is
u versus v is is cosine squared theta
and of getting opposite outcomes is
uh
sine squared theta
so
so now let's look at this this classical
model we came up with so so what happens
there
well in in this case what happens is
if we look if you look at these matched
coins
in two different directions
which make an angle of theta with each
other
right then we'll see
matching outcomes except with
probability theta
uh something proportional to theta
right so the only way we could get
different outcomes is if the coin
happens to be aligned so that it's it's
pointing exactly somewhere in this
direction
right it's a line aligned along this and
that the chances of that are
proportional to theta
and so
so
you know so the chance of um
of getting different answers
is really theta versus it should be sine
squared theta right the chance of
getting different different outcomes
and
that's where quadratic difference comes
in right because sine squared theta for
theta small is like theta squared
and so so the chance of getting
different answers is
is theta in this classical
picture
but it's it's theta squared in the in
the in the quantum picture so it's so so
in the quantum
picture we get we get much
higher chance of of uh
of getting uh you know of being
coordinated
across this uh
you know across these two possibilities
and so
so this is you know we we could sort of
say this is really the crux of the
matter you know the the fact that
together with actually changing bases
it's you know the fact that it's uh that
we are working with um with this
quadratic
you know it's l2 instead of l1 maybe
that's that's where this
test of quantumness comes in
okay so
so um
so now this um
uh you know this l2 versus l1 has
everything to do with uh you know stps
versus lps so
um in fact there's this there's this uh
class of games called xor games where
where the output
outputs a and b
are are bits always and the success of
failure
of the two players in the game depends
upon
you know it's a function of uh
um
of a x or b
so what what sales ensured is that in
fact
um
you know there
for such games there's an optimal
strategy
there's there's always an optimal
strategy where you have a finite number
of bits of entanglement so so so in
other words you know
uh these two players uh a and b
we can you know no matter what how we
define the the game uh there's there's
only a finite amount of entanglement
that they need to use in order to in
order to um
maximize this their probability of
success
and once you do that you can actually
write the maximum success probability as
as a as an stp
and in the case of uh in the case of uh
um
the chsh game the
you know um
the the cosine squared pi by eight the
point eight five probability of success
is really the optimal probability of
success so there so we have a optimal
strategy of uh for for solving the that
problem in fact um
i guess since we'll refer to it to this
at times i may as well just make it
concrete and say
what the strategy is so so depending
upon whether alice's input is zero one
she measures her qubit in one of two
bases either either the standard basis
or the pi by four rotated basis and
similarly bob does does the same he
either measures in the in one basis or
another depending upon his input and
and the point about this choice of bases
is that is that
in in three of the four cases where
where the where the end of x and y is
is zero
the
the two bases in which alice and bob are
measuring are are pi by eight
apart okay so
so now uh you know this was this was the
story as of uh as of um
a few years ago and um what's happened
recently is that um
is that um
you know we we have a
you know
a deeper understanding of of these games
um
which which has come about from
from uh exploring various applications
of these these uh these kinds of
entangled games
and
so
so the kinds of applications include
certified certifiable randomness
device independent qkd and
testing quantum mechanics and quantum
computers and so the the theme in all
this is
how do you
you know how do you deal with untrusted
quantum devices and how do you take
these tests for quantumness and and
extend them to actually test that these
quantum devices are behaving properly
right so certainly the first thing you
have to do is test that they are really
quantum but but how do you actually
adapt these tests to to make them even
more interesting
um okay so
so let me let me uh spend
um the rest of the talk just giving you
a very quick outline of of some of these
uh applications and
and
and what the you know what what
additional information you have to know
about these these tests for quantumnessa
to to
to
actually get these applications
okay so the first application has to do
with certifiable quantum random
generators
so
so the idea here is that quantum
mechanics gives us a way of generating
randomness just through
you know creating a bell state and
measuring it sorry or even a qubit and
measuring it in some some basis
but now
what if we really don't trust our
quantum devices so
can we can we somehow
get in
a random number
and
certify that this particular random
output was random you know that this
particular output was generated randomly
without assuming anything about the
device that's that's actually generating
it
right so it's sort of um it's it's a
funny thing to do to certify that a
particular number is is random
um
because usually you you you think of
that as being not you know as being
impossible unless you unless you turn to
something like kolmogorov complexity you
know uh something like that
so
so the
the
very interesting thing is that somehow
what you can do is
well you you do need to start with a
with a short random seed
and then you have some quantum black
boxes which which perform some sort of
chsh like test you know some kind of
bell inequality
uh test so so you have a classical
player who who performs these bell
inequality
violation tests on the outputs of these
boxes
and based on that you can actually
certify that the output is really random
and therefore
that that random string that you extract
from that using a using a quantum
extractor is really has really been
picked from close to a
close to a uniform distribution
okay so
so
let me just try to go back and say so
so i'm assuming in here that maybe what
these what these boxes are doing you
know so the rod short random seed is
used to pick the input to these two to
these boxes which are performing chsh
games
and so
um
so let's go back and see what is it
about the chsh game that we need to know
in order to say that in fact the output
is going to be random
okay so before we said
that
in the case that
that
that the boxes are classical you cannot
achieve a success probability of greater
than
three quarters in in achieving this goal
but if they are quantum then you can
achieve something like 0.85
and so if you if you achieve more than
three quarters you have a violation of
this of this three of this bell
inequality
and so you have a test of quantumness
so now what we can say is actually
that
the condition is slightly different that
that if these boxes
were using stale randomness randomness
that had been generated in the past
then in fact
this bound of three quarters hurts
but if they
you know but but the condition for for
for getting beyond this three quarters
is that the randomness must be
you know must have been brewed right at
that moment
right it's it's it's got to be served up
hot otherwise you you don't get beyond
three quarters
and so
and so if you get a violation of a bell
inequality then you know that the output
must be random and that's what these
schemes use
okay so
so now you know the next application has
has to do with uh quantum cryptography
where
you know now what what alice and bob
wish to do is is
um they wish to create a secret key
so
so so now they want to generate
randomness they want to generate a
random key
but but there's an additional condition
which is that the the keys that they
they generate
are identical
and they're also
um secret from an eavesdropper who's
trying to listen in on the line
okay so this is really the the central
problem in in quantum cryptography
and
and the whole point of quantum
cryptography was that you could solve
this problem provably securely meaning
that meaning that uh the eavesdropper
has no chance of of compromising this uh
you know the the the randomness of the
key
um
unless
you know unless quantum mechanics is
violated
right so um
so this was great except that every time
people actually built these devices
there were there were always ways to
to cheat
and
and so the
the real problem is that
is that um in practice these you know
designing these boxes so that they don't
leak information
alongside channels is very hard
and so
in fact
you know
a different way you can look at this
problem is
one of the one of the issues is one of
the main issues in in quantum
cryptography is that is that assuming
that that your quantum devices are
perfect are trusted is is really not a
good assumption
now of course it you know since it's
cryptography we may as well go
all the way in and say well actually
these these are black boxes the quantum
devices are black boxes
and that
moreover you know they were actually
designed by the eavesdropper because how
do you know who did you purchase them
from so let's say that that in fact
these these black boxes were designed by
by the eavesdropper who is actually
shares entanglement with these boxes and
now the challenge is
can alice and bob feel secure
that they have generated the same key
it's random
but it's also random looking to the
eavesdropper
okay so
um
so actually one of the
you know one of the early pro you know
one of the protocols for quantum
cryptography not the bb-84
but uh but eckerd's protocol
um you know in his paper he made this
observation sort of saying
perhaps this this protocol has this
additional prop has this additional
property because he said well
you know
since since what we want is that this
this shared uh
um
bell state between these two devices
is in this singular state
that we are testing through through
violation of bell's inequality
then
neither of these two particles can be
correlated with a third particle without
disturbing the purity of this this
singlet state so he was already hinting
at this whole idea that somehow this
this
entanglement is monogamous
and once you you know if you if you
verify in any sense that
that that alice and bob are really using
the the two devices are really using
this kind of a bell state to generate
the randomness then then in fact
you cannot have the eavesdropper
listening
okay so
this is really something that you can
prove that if a and b are maximally
entangled they cannot share any
entanglement with c
but the but the real problem that comes
in is what if some of the qubits of a
and b are maximally entangled
but others are not
right because after all these are black
boxes they can have a huge albert space
and some part of the hilbert space can
be entangled
and so you you really have to now
stretch this whole notion of monogamy in
order to prove that these protocols work
okay so so now let's see what what this
tells us about the chsh game so now it
says
not only
does violation of a bell inequality give
us
fresh randomness but it's all it's also
fresh and private randomness
you know it you know just the fact that
you violated bell inequalities tells you
that this randomness
you know
after you massage it a little bit
couldn't possibly have been shared by
any other any other party
okay so
so now
we can go further with this with with
the chsh game and and try to understand
well what does it really tell us if if
we
you know if if we violate this this
spell inequality
um
so it turns out there's a there's a
rigidity to to the chsh game which
which sort of
follows by applying
uh somehow this stp characterization you
know serial students uh
characterization of of chsh and and
what this rigidity theorem says is that
suppose we know that alice and bob
win their game with probability close to
the maximum that they can
so with uh
epsilon close to the maximum
then in fact the only way they can do
this
is if they actually share a bell
pair and perform
measurements according to this optimal
chsh strategy that i that i pointed out
so
let's look at what this is saying so we
start off you know from alice and bob's
point of view you know these were black
boxes we don't understand what the
internal hybrid space is
but what what the rigidity theorem says
is no matter what
no matter how alice and bob choose to
organize their spaces
there must be some unitary
transformation on alice's side and some
unitary transformation on bob's side on
on his base so that after you're done
with this transformation
there's there's a qubit analysis side
and a qubit on bob's side which are
perfectly entangled in in a bell state
intensive product with everything else
or at least you know square root has
launched close to that
and they actually end up making
you know almost
the exact measurements that chsh
asks them to
okay
in fact this even this even holds in a
in a multi-game setting so
so let's you know let's say we play end
games
and now alice and bob just collect
collect
statistics
and if they've been close to this cosine
squared pi by a fraction of the gains
then they can actually
infer from that
that
that the internal structure of alice and
bob's
spaces up to unitary transformation of
of their local spaces
corresponds to
some number
you know of of
of bell states
in tensor product with each other and in
terms of product with the rest of the
space so once you have this kind of
control you know so now this says that
that a classical verifier can have
you know just by performing these simple
tests can really control what's going on
inside these boxes
at least to the extent of making them
you know perform one of two measurements
and once you have this much control over
over a classical device you can actually
use use them you can actually direct
their computation in any way that you
want
okay so i think ben will tell you a lot
more about this
uh this kind of theorem
um
i should say that um
there there are they're actually um you
can you can go beyond this kind of uh
entanglement scenario in terms of
testing of quantumness
and so
let's say you have a you have a you have
a
company called cuvee that that announced
a black box
which they claim is quantum
and you re you you wish to test that
it's really a quantum computer
so
so now you could you could carry out
some kind of uh
um
you know uh a dialogue with this
computer
so well ideally what you want is as a
classical being to carry out a dialogue
but let's say we throw in all sorts you
know let's say let's say that we also
give
arthur the
the capability of dealing with
a constant number of qubits so preparing
a constant number of qubits and sending
it to to to the computer repeatedly
so in this setting it turns out you can
verify any any quantum computation
so you can take a untrusted quantum
device and you can really verify that it
carried out the computation that you
desired
um
okay but but now you can you can
sort of
take this
you know all the way to to the to the
next step and you can say well what
about testing quantum mechanics itself
can you can you use some of these ideas
to test quantum mechanics
so
well why would we want to do that well
um here's the reason the you know so
in in physics um
you know it's always been fruitful to
test the limits of a theory you know in
the in the limits of high energy or very
small sizes or very large velocities
and so
well
you know what quantum computation has
pointed out is that is that there's
another limit which is extremely
counter-intuitive which is
you know as the system size gets gets
larger in terms of the size of the
hilbert space then something
very counter-intuitive happens and so
we'd actually want to
test quantum mechanics in indo in that
limit
and
but of course there's a problem which is
in order to test it in that limit we've
got to be actually able to compute
what quantum mechanics predicts in that
limit and that takes exponential time in
general
so
so the difficulty is how do you
how do you
actually
do science when you cannot even
calculate what what your theories
are you know should predict
and um
the the the
uh you know the idea is well one could
use this same sort of
scenario where
where we think of the experimentalist as
carrying out an
an interactive
sort of proof or an interactive
experiment with their experimental setup
so instead of computing in advance what
the
what the outcome of the experiment
should be
they actually carry out some sort of an
interactive uh proof
have to have the experimental apparatus
give an experi an interactive proof that
it's behaving as quantum mechanics
really does predict
and of course
you know there's there's this um what
these previous results show is that
suitably augmented
you really can carry this out
but um if you really insist on arthur
being completely classical and and
and the experimental apparatus or merlin
being being quantum and polynomial time
banded
well then
you know we we don't yet know whether we
can actually do it in completely in this
scenario and that's a very interesting
open question so i should stop here and
thank you
so uh i just have a quick question you
mentioned um about the chs stage games
and you said that that um that
constrained it up to a local unitary
uh my understanding is that you can also
have complex conjugation
uh in the in the encoding
so if you if you complex conjugate all
your states
and all your operators
it doesn't give you a unity encoding
from one to the other but you can still
pass
the games
does this cause any difference
right
so um
um
okay so so
maybe i should i should back up a little
bit so so in general
um
um
in order to you know to prove the
theorem you you really have to
attach an ancella because um
you know so so it it wouldn't actually
be a
a unitary general it would be unitary
after you attach and
yeah
even even so
there's still this transformation you
can make by just complex conjugating
everyone and that's not that's not even
free operation
the complex contributor
okay but for the operators it won't be
the case
another question
something to ask it's not a very
impressive thing
so you are verifying that the chsh game
creates
or uses private granular messages
so what does
no sorry so so it's it's that um
it's that the randomness must be fresh
rather than
you know so um
so it's not that the the two players
must have uh
their own randomness
um because in a in a sense it it is the
same you know it is
it is um i see you're saying it's
private to the two of them as opposed to
public to
uh to everybody
oh yeah yeah okay so so
i see so you're referring to the
monogamy of entanglement yeah so um so
basically uh you know what
what what that's saying is
so suppose you have two qubits which are
maximally entangled
right and they're really qubits and
they're you know and they happen to be
completely entangled
well then there's no room for them to be
entangled with anything else
and so if you were to measure one of
them
you know you get a random outcome
and of course it's
that random outcome is shared by both of
both of the qubits
but now because these these qubits are
completely unentangled with the rest of
the world
um you know this randomness is private
to these two these two qubits you know
if you measure these two qubits you you
get that randomness but nothing outside
can share
that randomness it means that
if they play the chess game
0.85
efficiency yeah then they cannot be
entangled in like any outside that's
right
that's what it means yeah
yeah and so um
uh
um you know so the the challenge in in
in
making all this all this work in in
these settings that i talked about is
that well first of all you you won't get
perfect uh
you know
you won't get cosine squared pi by eight
as your success probability it'll be
below that
and so so there's a possibility of some
entanglement with with
but then
in addition to that
you know these are not just qubits it's
it's some device so it's a large number
of qubits and so
even though you know some of them are
entangled between alice and bob there
are many many other degrees of freedom
that could be entangled with eve
and
now you know you want to say well the
monogamy
property still holds for
those qubits that you're actually
measuring for the chsh game even though
these devices are are actually in turn
could be entangled
yes
if you think about in terms of
probability density matrices conjugation
of the wave function is just a linear
transformation of that so it's still a
unitary and once you append an ancillary
space it's still a unique transformation
so it's nothing new
so i mean this is really determined do
you expect it to hold for other
inequalities or which are kind of the
features of css that makes this possible
so sorry which one the unity theorem i
mean
yeah yeah so so the um
i i think in at least in the multi-game
rigidity theorem we actually used a lot
of
features of the chsh game so
um
i think is is it correct that there are
there are games which are not rigid even
though
we have kind of
yeah i actually like your stale and
fresh randomness
um i mean you know you think about
coffee it's very intuitive right you all
know what you're talking about but i
mean i have a similar question high
dimensions how would you define that
right i mean if you have a high
dimensional
state i guess
or i mean it is i mean two dimensions
you can somehow compare it with your
cosine pi over square bound
pale right bound but i mean what does
fresh render means in high dimension
is there is there a definition or is it
just
um
i i guess um you know the way the way
these theorems are proved you you say
that if a bell inequality is violated
then the output must must have
randomness in it you know that there
must be a certain amount of min entropy
in the in the output
and then you can extract it okay okay
bye
one last question before we follow up on
maurice is going to get coffee
okay just a quick one ah it seems to me
if you make your r2 completely classical
then there is no way that merlin can
convince of quantum mess because it
could have been a single super classical
machine simulating it so
in the case of the signal
yeah no you're right so we have to
define the task carefully
so um
you know out here we we don't really
you're right that we
we cannot know that what's going on
inside is classical or quantum so
it could definitely be the case that
that that what's in here is a
supercomputer which is working for an
incredible amount of time and it's
classically computing what the right
answers are
so
so we don't really want this to be a
test of content as we want it to be a
test that
in fact the answers are correct
that they are compatible with what they
would be if what was going on in here
was truly quantum well this is still
that question could be interesting to
see what is a real level but if you want
to also the test of quantum lessons
imagine how we change the correctness to
be some aspect of quantumness yes okay
so now what is the lover
of that article
yeah so so in in the situation that
you're describing where you really want
to
you you really want to verify the
dynamics you want to verify the quantum
dynamics of what's going on in here then
you you know you can get that from this
rigidity theorem by saying suppose you
have you have two such
labs which cannot communicate with each
other and then then you carry out this
this kind of
rigidity theorem and based on that you
can actually
verify the dynamics
let's thank
again
you